One really handy feature of Xcode is
that Alt+clicking on a class can take
you directly to its documentation.
Let's take a closer look
at the documentation for
the UIViewController class.
Let's see what we can find in
the Interacting with Storyboard section.
You're already familiar with
the storyboard property,
which we used to get a reference
to the dice view controller.
We've also seen prepareForSegue and
performSegueWithIdentifier.
It's good to become comfortable
with these methods and
properties now, because they'll all come
into play again soon as we begin to work
with navigation controllers.
Let's go ahead an implement
prepareForSegue in our
RollViewController file.
I want you to pay close attention
to this segue argument,
because it has some information
that we really need right now.
In particular, the segue has this
destinationViewController property,
which in this case is
the DiceViewController.
And now that we have a reference
to the DiceViewController,
we can set the dice values.
And now let's try running it.
Sweet!
We've got dice!